[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
on
[Musique]
on cherche à éprouver au maximum les
capacités humaines pour qu'ensuite on
puisse aller comprendre ce qui se passe
dans notre cerveau qu'est-ce que
l'impact d'un millier aussi difficile
que samaras ont des fonctions cognitives
[Musique]
c'est un projet qui est extrêmement
novateur et en fait on le sait rien là
dessus pour le serbe se marrer
c'est la traversée des quatre îles yeux
des plus extrêmes de la planète les
espaces d'abord splendide qui nous font
rêver mais qui nous soumettent à des
situations qui nous dépasse donc j'ai
pensé que ce serait deux fois et
apprendre comment l'humain peut évoluer
et exister dans ce milieu c'est des
dizaines des centaines d'émotion sujet
auj ce qui nous intéresse et nous
mais bon c'est de voir comment fait au
sarod va s'adapter j'ai également des
aspects liés à la motivation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons devoir explorer
mars des océans l'univers mais nous
devons surtout explorer ce que nous
sommes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis depuis maintenant 20 ans que je
fais des expéditions je me suis souvent
posé la question ce qui était d'être un
explorateur je vais dans tous les
milieux de la planète j'y vais parfois
tout seul parfois en emmenant des
groupes d'expédition un peu partout mais
ce qui fait vraiment l'exploration c'est
que dans les milieux où je vais à chaque
instant tout le temps tout peut se
transformer à tout moment je ne sais
jamais ce qui va se passer la minute
d'après l'instant d'après et dans ce
sens nous sommes tous et toutes des
explorateurs parce que nous vivons dans
un monde qui est en évolution
un monde qui change ça c'était notre
monde ya quelques temps ça c'est notre
monde aujourd'hui
il a quelques objets qui nous regarde
quelques modifications il ya on parle
beaucoup du réchauffement climatique du
changement des évolutions des
désertification des inondations des
déplacements de population imaginez-vous
ça fait quelques générations goût de
famille vit dans un même endroit là bas
dans une petite vallée sympa et que jour
vient vous dire vous avez une semaine
pour prendre les affaires que vous
voulez et partir et ne jamais plus
revenir ici pour y penser ce que ça fait
pour quelqu'un parce que simple est ce
que ces impacts que ça implique
et puis bien sûr c'est un jugement
beaucoup plus rapide les tsunamis on a
les crises économiques
on a malheureusement l'idée qu'on peut
aller aujourd'hui écouter un concert et
que tout peut basculer
et puis on a ces nouvelles maladies
on pense que 10% la population fera un
burn-out dans les dix prochaines années
les maladies post traumatique
bref toutes des choses qui sont pas très
sympathique mais vous savez finalement
le changement qui fait presque le plus
peur aux gens que tout leur pose la
question les deux changements qui encore
aujourd'hui questionne le plus
la bille en couple et puis à l'autre
truc
un détail qui arrive de temps en temps à
des gens savez ce truc dont on parle
tout le temps dans tout le monde vous
dit tu verras dans neuf mois tout va
changer ta vie va changer
vous lisez des bouquins tout ça qui
compte le premier arrive je peux vous
dire vous êtes complètement perdus avec
ce qui se passe si tout change et ça
c'est intéressant parce que 11,1 pouces
préparer les changements être quand même
là il vaut quand même évolué et comment
nous perturber puis bien sûr et six
nouveaux changements comme
l'intelligence artificielle qui hantera
d'évoluer qu'est ce que ça va devenir
les gens comme richard hawkins ou lots
de mox qui disent que ça peut être le
plus grand danger du 21e siècle je sais
pas je sais qu'on n'arrêtera pas tout ça
je sais que je changerais pas ça je sais
que j'ai un seul outil pour me permettre
de vivre mieux tout ça c'est mon cerveau
est le vôtre
et ça c'est pas mal parce que c'est pour
ça que quelque part aujourd'hui je me
balade un peu partout dans la terre ou
dans les endroits les plus extrêmes avec
des électrodes sur la tête et un peu
partout pour essayer de comprendre
fondamentalement dans une situation de
changement de zone roger plus de
communication plus de moyens d'avoir des
contacts avec l'extérieur ou les
tempêtes pour arriver à tout moment ce
qui se passe dans le cerveau parce que
je pense que nous ne pourrons pas
évoluer et faire changer notre manière
d'évoluer dans le changement sont
comprendre fondamentalement ce qu'est et
comment fonctionne notre cerveau dans
les situations extrêmes
alors je me balade par exemple qu'un
hall désert de dasht e luton iran il
fait 57 degrés 2 % d'humidité assez
sympa parce qu'à 2 % d'humidité n'y a
plus rien doki reste nulle part même pas
dans le corps alors dans notre milieu
assez sympa c'est la patagonie avec le
mouvement le plus versatile qui soit on
sait jamais ce qui va se passer dans la
minute qui suivait les quatre saisons
qui défilent de la journée ça c'est
sympa
ou alors la masoni 1 44 degrés sont %
d'humidité et quelques copains qui se
balade autour de vous
je les aime bien je vous aime bien et
puis ça peut être aussi en sibérie à 58
degrés négatif est assez sympa parce que
vous êtes vraiment dans un endroit vous
êtes dans un congélateur qui chez vous
êtes à 18° moi je sais moi d'être à
moins 58 degrés dans la tente il fait
moins 50 degrés vous avez des petits
oiseaux qui vous passent devant de temps
en temps qu'il chantonne et vous vous
êtes comme ça quand je les ai là c'est
intéressant de savoir ce qui se passe
dans votre cerveau c'est là que ça
devient vraiment fort c'est là qu'on se
questionne sur ce qu'on est dans une
situation qui le dépasse complètement
et ça c'est ce que j'ai compris dans
différentes expéditions alors je vais
pas vous faire encore sur le cerveau je
vous rassure mais je vais vous dire
quelques notions timon apparus au fur et
à mesure de mes expéditions comme assez
importantes qui sont des évolutions du
cerveau quand on est dans une situation
nouvelle alors par exemple ça se passe
encore dire de darwin c'est une des mes
premières grosses explorer exploration
on part avec deux amis dans une chaîne
de montagnes qui est la plus complète du
monde thème climatique
vous avez des tempêtes tout le temps
alors vous parez vous vous explorez la
les glaciers puis tout d'un coup une
tempête sont 100 km/heure 200 km heure
devant car il séduire quelques minutes
ça s'arrête
tout ça c'est normal ça fait partie du
jeu on explore puis un soir vous avez
une tempête qui s'installe un peu plus
violente en vous avez juste que ton
installer votre compte et puis durant la
nuit la tempête devient de plus en plus
violentes de plus en plus forte
vous perdez une tente vous êtes à trois
dans une petite tente pour 2 puis toute
la journée suivante c'est la tempête la
tempête la plus terrifiante que j'ai vu
180 km à 1 devant 200 jeux c'est pas
énorme
et puis ça dure toute la journée qu'un
deuxième jour un troisième jour d'un
quatrième jour un cinquième jour vous ne
pouvez pas sortir de la tente
vous êtes coincé à 3 couché avec la
toile de tente qui vous bat la figure
c'est pas des 3 bougez les deux autres
bougent avec bon heureusement n'a de la
musique
ça c'est en permanence tout le temps ça
vous balaye les oreilles ça vous balaye
la figure c'est ça bouge tout le temps
vous êtes en stress total et ça continue
six jours sept jours huit jours neuf
jours dix jours onze jours ça ne
s'arrête pas douze jours 13 jours ça
fait cinq jours qu'on n'a plus à manger
le bateau qui doit venir le rechercher
ne pourra pas venir donc commencé
gentiment avoir votre tête qui tourne
dans tous les sens alors si vous voulez
essayer c'est pas compliqué un projet
l'acteur en vaut-il à tort dans le
congélateur deux amis et puis hop aussi
c'est sympa c'est que quatre jours d'une
vie après tour mais quinze jours ou 13
pour nous dans cette situation là ça
change tout il avoue réalisé que premier
réflexe vous battre contre ça d'essayer
de changer des choses de bouger de
qu'est ce qu'on fait en panique on est
on peut pas arrêter le vent pourtant
j'ai pas de prise sur le vent je peux
rien faire je suis coincé et là j'arrive
à cette notion de l'acceptation tant que
je n'ai pas accepté cette situation je
lutte contre elle
je me bats je trouve j'utilise l'énergie
fondamental à lutter contre ça et ça
marche pas parce qu'on peut pas lutter
contre le vent on peut pas lutter contre
le bateau qui pourra pas revenir on peut
pas lutter contre la nourriture qui
manquent
il faut accepter il faut repartir de ça
et construire autour
moi par exemple la manière de construire
ça a été de commencer à noter tout ce
que je voyais tout ce que je sentais
tout ce que je voyais sur moi sur mes
collègues parce qu'on avait des
réactions assez folle jeudi
vous apprenez à connaître vos copains et
vous apprenez aussi à vous connaître et
c'est pas toujours agréables et la jeune
tout et je construit autour de ça et si
on m'avait dit que dix ans plus tard ça
allait devenir des premiers groupes de
recherche au monde à réunir des
laboratoires pour questionner comment la
cognition humaine se transforme dans des
situations extrêmes
je l'aurais pas cru mais c'est ça que ça
a donné cette acceptation de considérer
que je pouvais construire quelque chose
autour d'une situation qui me dépassait
totalement alors bien sûr une fois qu'on
a accepté il faut commencer à bouger un
peu parce que la situation est quand
même pas sympa de cas je pense qu'il
faut avoir un esprit de conquête alors
l'esprit de conquête c'est facile
un drapeau
sommet echl ah ouais c'est le meilleur
je rêvais pas danger est toujours là je
crois pas que ce soit ça l'esprit de
conquête on ne n'est plus allé poser un
drapeau et se dire connaît les meilleurs
parce que j'ai posé mon drapeau et qu'il
ya mon nom sur le sommet je crois
sincèrement que puisque nous sommes tous
des explorateurs cet esprit de conquête
ils passent dans l'idée que l'on peut
agir que l'on a les moyens on ou se
donner une envie majeur systématique
toujours d'essayer d'avancer de créer
parce que la meilleure contestation
contre une situation c'est pas la lutte
c'est la création c'est le développement
c'est la construction c'est
l'apprentissage c'est la capacité qu'on
a de voir dans un tout petit point où si
minuscule soit il l'étincelle qui pourra
devenir parce qu'il ya toujours une
étincelle et que quand on a la capacité
de voir l'étincelle ça veut dire que
dans l'imagination suffisante pour voir
loin pour voir au delà de la situation
pour se dire que ok là maintenant je ne
suis ni tempête il fait 200 km heure
devant je peux rien faire mais y aura
quelque chose après alors évidemment cet
esprit de conquête cette volonté
d'avancer toujours et encore dans un
monde qui ne s'était en gens qu'il
connaît mal finalement
forcément ça permet cette capacité de se
dire tiens qu'est-ce que je connais
qu'est-ce que je connais pas le monde il
était connu comme ça en 1490 cas que
l'on va vers le roi du portugal pour le
dire j'ai envie d'aller explorer et
l'aura du portugais lui répond on
connaît déjà tous surtout mon ami et
pourtant il manquait quelques petits
bourgs et c'est ça il faut oser il faut
dépasser la peur que nous avons d'aller
vers quelque chose qui nous est inconnue
et cette peur pour la dépasser n'y a
qu'une chose qui permet de le faire y en
a plein mais il ya une chose en justice
au sein de courage le courage c'est pas
d'aller marcher notre parti s'est pas de
grimper sur un sommet si je suis capable
de le faire
c'est pas du courage le courage c'est
d'oser aller dire les choses qui nous
dérange qui nous inquiète ce qui nous
font peur qui nous touche
moi je suis un être pétri de peur c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait mes expéditions
parce que j'ai peur je suis encore en
vie parce que j'ai peur j'ai su dépasser
ça
et ça c'est fondamental cette notion là
elle est capitale
et pour le faire on a un outil génial
c'est quand même notre cerveau alors le
cerveau je peux nous en parler beaucoup
mais il ya un truc qui m'a toujours
intrigué imaginez vous avez une
connaissance à avoir quand vous naissez
on vous dit vous allez devoir savoir ça
ça ça puis vous deux vous augmentez la
connaissance vous donnez de mieux en
mieux
vous donnez un expert dans la
connaissance en expert de la situation
vous êtes le meilleur dans le cadre
qu'on vous a fixé et le cadre échanges
et la voûte super block 2/4 et là vous
allez construire il rentre plus ça
marche pas vous êtes le meilleur dans
votre domaine et votre domaine existe
plus peut-être qu'au lieu d'avoir une
grosse masse de connaissances il vaut
mieux avoir plein de connaissances
certes quelques une importante
quelques-unes solide les structures que
vous avez mais aussi plein de petites
choses des détails des choses que vous
avez en vous parce que quand le monde y
change peut-être que vous pourrez
utiliser chacune de ces petites
connaissances pour en créer une nouvelle
un nouveau monde un nouveau savoir et
c'est ça qui est fondamental cette
curiosité qu'on développe cette envie
d'aller vers des choses qui nous sont
impropres qu'on n'aime pas forcément
qu'on connaît mal mais qui nous
remplissent d'un savoir d'une
connaissance qui nous permettent de
construire un nouveau monde et de
l'explorer mais tout ça je crois que ça
suffit pas je crois qu'elle chose avant
tout ça quelque chose qui nous touche
fondamentalement quand on voit quelque
chose de merveilleux comme sait les
lions de mer en patagonie
cette idée toute simple qu'il faut
apprendre à s'émerveiller
parce que c'est très simple tant que
vous n'avez pas quelque chose qui vous
plaît qui vous donne envie qui vous et
merveilles de ce que vous êtes en train
de vivre
comment est ce que vous pouvez avoir
envie d'aller de l'avant et ça c'est
tout le temps c'est quand vous êtes en
patagonie tout seul avec vous de kayak
et vous fait jeter à l'eau par une
tempête que vous êtes dans une eau à 12°
que votre kayak est loin de vous que
vous nagez que vous vous épuisez que
vous n'en pouvez plus vous réalisez que
vous pourrez pas le rejoindre
ce kayak et que vous êtes trop fatigué
pour continuer et que vous êtes à une
minute de basculer et à ce moment là il
ya un arc en ciel devant vous superbe
splendide
vous devriez nager continuez de vous
arrêter juste deux secondes pour le
regarder et soudainement vous avez une
nouvelle raison d'y aller et vous nagez
il vous rejoignez votre kayak
parce que c'est très simple
tant qu'on n'a pas quelque chose devant
nous qui nous émerveille
on peut que regarder derrière ce conte
avec était bien et moi j'ai envie de
regarder maintenant et demain
posez-vous toujours cette question
qu'est-ce qui m'émerveille et là vous
pourrez accepter la situation et là vous
pourrez avoir la conquête de cette
situation et là vous pourrez avoir le
courage de lui des comptes vous peur et
c'est pour ça que moi à ma manière
dans ce monde qui est quand même
extraordinaire qui est le mien et quelle
votre aussi j'ai envie
quelles que soient les tempêtes que je
vais affronter où les gens que j'aime et
que de temps en temps je devrai laisser
derrière moi de continuer d'explorer
demain et de le construire et d'y croire
mais ça c'est pas très important ça
c'est moi tout seul je ferais rien moi
la question j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est et vous est ce que vous serez
explorateurs avec moi je vous remercie
d'avoir écouté